the focus of attention now is across the
Tigris River to West Mosul thousands
upon thousands of civilians still live
here but this is the readout of Islamic
state where they will use the myriad of
streets and alleyways to fight to the
death it is their last stand in Iraq in
the video you're about to see
illustrates the type of people the Iraqi
Special Forces are fighting
this is crazy crazy stuff he's high on
adrenaline maybe something else one of
the men uses his radio to urge other
fighters on
they're putting so many rounds down his
weapon becomes super hot but he keeps
dying
we don't know what happens later but
they probably died here we believe this
little boy filmed the firefight dressed
in military fatigues he appears on the
same tape you're singing a song of going
to war and killing people and defending
the Islamic state
it is horrendously sad we don't know
where he is
it all took place here the University
Special Forces found the camera and pass
it to us it was the headquarters of is
in Mosul it's destroyed now Iraq you say
the buildings were set alight by Islamic
state some are likely to escape this way
to a bridge over the river it's now a
scary no-man's land
rockets and mortars whistle overhead in
both directions securing the bridges
will be the key to take in the West all
of the bridges that cross the Tigris
River the linking East and West have
been dropped but they've done it in such
a way that actually they can be mended
temporarily at least quite quickly and
that's exactly what it intended to
happen the first troops coming from the
south will go along the west side of the
river get to the bridges and start
making them working and others can come
over sounds very easy it isn't of course
100% of the time they will be under fire
not just from machineguns and RPGs but
also suicide bombers the first convoy of
Special Forces Humvees and trucks are
now been withdrawn from inside the city
in preparation for the move on the
Western banks of the Tigris commanders
say they're confident of success I think
I think it's simple why because the
Dodge has many many commander and many
fighter in the
and many common controls destroyed for
example in the university
command-and-control and the other side
is a small area it's not be carried on
many many told when we're starting hope
we can in the same site next step the
markets in Mosul are open again a sign
of the improving situation a dressmaker
works on his new collection for 2017 is
the first time in two years he hasn't
made a dress that wasn't entirely black
outside he tells me it's nice to use
colors again and on a mannequin they
were banned as well a clear sexual
object according to Islamic state banned
as well pretty colorful bangles and
clothes and our families are shopping
again things are changing for certain
but the fighting here is far from over
the military is never far away
Stewart Ramsey Sky News Mosley